ce dimanche 10 avril les runner sont
venus en nombre à guyancourt il était
387 inscrit à la 22e édition de la glu
en course
la compétition est organisée comme
chaque année par l'entente athlétique de
saint quentin en yvelines
c'est une course qui est vraiment à
portée locale les coureurs viennent de
saint quentin en yvelines bien sûr
puisque ça rendez vous attendu à 50 1
mais viennent aussi du département voire
des départements limitrophes hauts
niveaux catégorie on au registre
aujourd'hui une personne qui a plus de
90 ans
pour ce 10 km les spectateurs ont eu le
droit à un duel de haute voltige
françois l'acquis qui travaillent à
montigny le bretonneux s'est imposé en
34 minutes et 17 secondes
le sportif a devancé de 9 secondes
auront boli temps alain jarry on essaie
de courir en tête la paix la moitié de
la course après ça s'est joué sur la
seule difficulté de là quasiment de la
journée dans la fameuse côte entre les
deux étangs et là il est un petit peu
coincé et après l'écart s'est fait et
j'essaie de maintenir belle course je
tiens à féliciter le premier il a fait
une belle course il est parti au bon
moment dans la côte
voilà je ne connaissais pas trop le
parcours donc je ne nie pas osé partir
avec lui et je pense avoir bien fait
parce qu'il était quand même très solide
et mérite sa victoire je félicite alain
jarry pourrait prendre sa revanche en
2016 les deux runner devrait s'aligner
l'année prochaine sur la 23e édition de
la nuit aux courses